certain territories will still be
returned and we will continue to continue to
consult with the population who
expresses a desire to live with Russia
in the Andreeva Kryvyi Rih direction,
units of the Russian army
hold their positions repelling
attacks by superior enemy forces
during hostilities in the area of ​​​​the
settlement of Novaya Kamenka,
Kherson region, there were
up to 30 nationalists were destroyed two tanks
four infantry fighting vehicles
reported that
a whole number of categories of our citizens do not
need to be called up as part of
mobilization and listed
but relevant changes to the
regulatory framework
and therefore
presented
in such a way that they did not initially take into account the
position of the Ministry itself and  I have
to make appropriate adjustments to this document
Today I have already submitted
[music] for release
where
these same adjustments are made